hey what's up everybody welcome to the
are you garbage comedy podcast please
take a second to subscribe to the
YouTube channel that way you get the
episodes as they come out thanks a lot
hey gang it's your old pals uncle Hank
and Kippy Kevin James Ryan special
announcement the ru garbage patreon is
alive oh baby it is up and running clean
living go to patreon.com/scishow Devery
week we're gonna have stuff me and Foley
from the hard feelings archive we're
gonna do live streams the whole nine
yards getting while you can buy low sell
high what they say so check it out
everybody go to patreon.com/scishow
garbage we need this welcome to another
exciting edition of ru garbage the show
where you find out if your favorite
comedians are classy individuals or
absolute trash now here are your hosts
Kevin Ryan and H Foley hey everybody
welcome back to everybody's favorite new
podcast this is ru garbage the show
where we sit down with your favorite
comedians and find out if they grew up
classy or if they grew up absolute trash
I am self-proclaimed garbage from
Philadelphia Pennsylvania I am your host
H Foley coming out here from what my
co-host described as my mom's mancave
here in suburban Philadelphia feeling
pretty good my co-host is at undisclosed
location
somewhere in the southern tip of the New
Jersey coastline ladies and gentlemen
Kevin James everybody up guys no longer
a secret North Wildwood New Jersey king
of the [ __ ] boardwalk come see me if
you want a shot at the title I'll be at
the [ __ ] Condor waiting for you guys
happy to be here thanks so much for
listening we appreciate it
if you're new to the show please make
sure you go rate review on iTunes full
videos up on YouTube you can subscribe
and comment there we appreciate it also
the patreon is launched to go check that
out as well very nice and folks I can't
tell you I can speak on behalf of Kevin
and I to let you folks know how
sorry that we are to have this
incredibly special guest here on the
podcast today you love them you wanted
them and let's take our time and go over
this rap sheet right here okay let's
start out with you seen him on guy code
you seen him on bender sneaky pete HBO's
crashing fake news at night Feast of the
Seven Fishes movie this week at the
Comedy Cellar funny pains documentary
about comedy alright he is he put on a
special a few years ago we recorded the
special some reason nobody wanted to buy
it so what did he do we started posting
the clips on YouTube and let me fast
forward to about 15 minutes ago this
young man has 1 million subscribers on
YouTube his special the crowd works
special has 2.4 million views he puts
out daily video and daily content that
Garner's millions of views hundreds of
thousands of views in a [ __ ] clip he
has his own multimedia studio he
performs sold-out shows to sold-out
crowds all over the [ __ ] world has
got some of the best fans in comedy all
right he is the he is the definition of
hard work determination and talent all
[ __ ] rolled into one
he's one of the goats he's one of the
kings he's the starting [ __ ]
quarterback he's the prom queen and the
prom king and from what I heard right
before the [ __ ] pandemic he was out
there at Teterboro Airport price
check-in Gulfstream fives but the big
question everybody mine today is he
garbage ladies and [ __ ] gentlemen as
I said many a times in person and I
can't wait to do it again give it up for
the one the only
Andrew Schultz everybody deserves tell
me it's true about the g5 if you start
flying private oh man I'm gonna have a
poster of you on my wall that's the next
step baby you can't be flying commercial
anymore yeah
that's how you get the red case
[Laughter]
everybody who went g5 and has like blue
you going private
Aziz went private every private got a
rape case or like a Cosby was flying
commercial Cosby was not in coach I know
that much he was flying [ __ ] private
in the 70s yeah yeah that's where you
got to go clean you got to go like burst
our flying helicopters everywhere that's
right that's a good one the helicopter
yeah could be a month three of them yeah
I don't know with your convictions when
it comes to weather I'm amazed with that
but either one of you ever get into a
helicopter with me if I had like three
years experience to fly in a helicopter
dude I don't even trust you saying the
word helicopter get the [ __ ] out of here
no [ __ ] way dude yeah yeah why not I
mean come on there's one of the ones
from Vietnam like a Huey I would love to
fly in one of those [ __ ] fire up the
m60 start [ __ ] leaned up I'd be
pretty fun little Rolling Stones playing
behind me go ahead Kippy I'm sorry buddy
no I was talking to mercy about flying
with bird he's just like yeah man like
if there's one person I do trust flying
a [ __ ] helicopter that's my boy it's
him and I was like I don't know if I
have one of those boys I'd fire you
schatzi Uncle Hank I'm right there with
them thanks buddy all right well let's
do we have limited time with you again
we thank you so much for being here this
is are you garbage before we start
asking you some questions to find out
what the situation is I want you to take
me through growing up in the city now a
lot of times on the show when we get to
the city kids it's a little bit it's a
little bit not difficult for us but it's
hard to like get that image of how City
kids grew up
because we're both trash from the
suburbs you know [ __ ] right I'm
riding dirt bikes in construction sites
and jumping creeks and all that kind of
stuff so I just want to get before we
get into the questions is you know take
me through how you grew up in the city I
know your family
you guys are kind of in the Union Square
area mostly right so I was like fourth
grade so before that I was like yeah I
don't know it's like I don't have
anything a compared to but people think
like growing up for the city's so weird
when I describe it to them but I just
don't understand what else there is
yeah so it's I I don't know I it's it's
hard for me describe it as odd
you know I guess I'd go over to my
apartment if there was a punk the
parents take you to the park hang out
when you get old enough to go out by
yourself you just hang out on a stoop
and you drink some 40s on a stoop or
something like that so maybe we didn't
have I don't know the [ __ ] local
McDonald's wherever you guys could hang
out a crate like that was what we we
just kind of felt found someplace
outside and I want to get into that more
specifically but before we get into that
tell me like what did your mom and dad
do growing up your mom it was a dancer
correct or is it kids all [ __ ] class
these are learning [ __ ] people he
comes from learning people well we want
what were we doing good on the cash at
this point like what your parents doing
well or did they start at the bottom
nah well my mom is like dirt poor from
Scotland came here and then she becomes
like the best generation she's like
three-time u.s. ballroom dance champion
and she's just like what yeah oh that
she's a beast man she's a beast so it's
like she came here and then my dad grew
up in Manhattan and then like when he
was a teenager they moved to Jersey to
Montclair New Jersey and then he was in
the army and then he got out of the army
he was in Baltimore then he got into the
news business he was like at the same
news station as Oprah and then too it's
crazy crazy and then my favorite friend
of his used to get head from Oh Jean I
do
yeah I said this the other day I said it
on Twitter you came through with the
[ __ ] the whole call or daddy business
when you [ __ ] did he go out on a date
with that chick you're like you're like
[ __ ] Forrest Gump of modern
entertainment right now he's just in the
middle of everything my dad my dad's
[ __ ] Oprah you know it's crazy but a
guy that he worked with said he used to
get from Oprah and he was like he
literally said we got the clip cut it
print it fatso let that run all right
Stu [ __ ] she's good I'll tell you that
she's good she's all right my father
said well my father's like memory is
gone he's like it's like he probably
doesn't remember telling me that's also
getting a [ __ ] from an early Oprah's
like something you don't tell for a
couple of years because you don't want
anybody know and then you're like oh
never mind I gotta I gotta head from
Oprah
you gotta wait to the peak oh yeah
that's when you drop that [ __ ] yeah yeah
so it's like like the more successful
you get the better girls feel about your
one-night stand
mm-hmm yeah you know saying like the
more like you're just so bummed you're
gonna man he really took me out of [ __ ]
but like really you start really making
it all of a sudden it was like a story
yeah yeah you're not some [ __ ]
landscaper or something that you know
you got head behind a Wendy's exactly
well yeah so and he came up to New York
and he produced the news in in New York
he did like these really cool stories
like he did the first ever story on like
hip-hop music like like Russell Simmons
and like he went up to the Bronx like
Grandmaster Flash you know these guys if
you do this really cool [ __ ] he was
always and he did a story on my mom and
then they just started dating and then
you know I became me and then he started
working with my
like basically running the dance studio
from like the managerial side and they
just talk partner dance was really cool
and they just did some some great stuff
for me they're like the perfect example
of like you just do something good and
good for you yeah really just like
preserved certain dance forms that
weren't popular but like my dad just
thought that they were beautiful my mom
thought they were beautiful they didn't
want them to die so like swing was one
of them like it was like my dad will get
written out of the history books with
swing but like the swing resurgence is
because my dad in the 90s I mean yeah
like so literally he went up to this
club I think was called the Cotton Club
in like Harlem and they were going and
he would go because there was this dance
and he would see like no kids were there
dancing swing and he was asking the guy
and girl put it on this old blah he's
all black couple he's like what's
happening to the dancing why isn't it
being passed on to the next generation
and they were just like yeah the youth
doesn't care so like you like ask this
guy who is one of the original Savoy
dancers like from the Savoy Ballroom or
whatever maybe he was a Savoy Ballroom
and I don't even know what that is
all he's never been in a ballroom so
it's a little nicer than the Cotton Club
it's not in Harlem we'd like to just
like keep it going calm music swing
dances like a random like restaurant
such like that just creating a place for
people to go out and like partner dance
since they're teaching lessons and then
swing exploded like yeah I just was not
for a while it was huge in LA - it was
there was a thing called West Coast
Swing in LA there was that movie
swingers and the the style of swing that
my parents taught and that was taught in
my parents fooled by these like Swing
legends
ends up becoming the big style and none
of the other Studios taught that style
so everyone came there it was like the
perfect example of like yo just do
things for the right reason and they
will get rewarded monetarily
yeah Jesus and I just remember going to
the studio and there'd be a [ __ ] 40
people in every single room when the
studio got bigger and it was like what a
crazy thing so we're talking about
classy people here and I
like that but this is the one thing
well immigrants can go either way we
found that real Scottish woman from the
hood outside Glasgow if I say her
neighbourhoods a Scottish people they're
like oh [ __ ] we found out this show is
called are you garbage or were you
raised by immigrant parents sometimes so
it's like the same it's the same thing
before we get to the questions I just
want to know take me on a typical night
as specific as possible now when you say
the East Village so you're what 35 36 so
you're talking you're 12 13 mid 90s
right yeah
so the East Village in the [ __ ] 90s
you're 12 13 years old you're obviously
not going out with your parents what are
you and your boys doing like are you
guys hop in the Train are you going at
the [ __ ] Coney Island not leaving the
city
12 13 so 13 is early man I'm trying to
think like 12 13 maybe were I wonder if
we were even gonna play pool we're
probably just gonna see a movie what we
did was there was I forget the exact age
of this but we figured out how to sneak
into my local movie theater there we go
movie theater had like this back both of
them there's one on 11th and third and
the other one was on 12th and second and
both of them have his back entrance so
we got one person to buy a ticket we
could go in and then sneak in the rest
of us through the side entrance and then
we figured out how to use like all the
back places where they like put the
garbage you know like they clean out the
movie theaters and then they go through
that little exit sign yeah we're going
to movie theater there's a gonna exit
sign right next to the screen yeah like
what we did and we found out like how to
kind of like get through so we just
watch movies that was it just like a
middle school right yeah something like
that but yeah I was born you don't do
anything as a kid in the city you know
like my private school friends they
weren't even really they weren't even
doing a lot
by then it's a weird age 12 13 you're
not doing a commuter city yeah you
picture I'm crazy I picture like
Basketball Diaries that's what I picture
you guys all high school high school
[ __ ] gets crazy ice cream yeah that's
when like that's when like you see the
kids start [ __ ] with drugs and then
like the private school kids like they
realize their parents don't really care
about the net much they start they not
been hoping to get attention so they're
throwing parties at their house and then
all the kids are come to the parties to
sell on the weed and they're stealing
from the house it's like a Law & Order
episode bro private school friends of
mine didn't call me in and specifically
they'd be like yo do you think you could
bring your black friends we got this
fight uptown and we but they say my
black just bring the black guys they'll
be intimidated yeah don't but don't
bring don't bring Tommy with you yeah
yeah yeah
it's crazy because like from suburban
kids to think of having firstly the
[ __ ] East Village having that is your
backyard crazy dude if it blows our
minds and I'm sure you know the opposite
but dude you know what it is it's like
you have all this freedom because you
can walk around and it's there's all
this [ __ ] going on but you can't do any
the [ __ ] so it's like and when you're in
the suburbs you walk around your
cul-de-sac and there's nothing to do and
I have better [ __ ] to look at but it's
actually worse because I'm just looking
at all the [ __ ] I'm not allowed to do
yet right
yeah I'm just as bored and people are
having fun crime happens in areas where
like you're like there's relative
poverty where it's like the poor people
live right next to the rich people
people see how in Haiti you're not
stealing because you're so like that's
what it was so yeah we got an earlier
start probably around like 17 18 Christ
are going to bars and clubs and that
kind of [ __ ] you're just [ __ ]
playing video games you're doing nothing
you're trying to like after your cable
box to get channel 35 that was like we
were doing the same things that was one
of my questions - oh yeah dude I mean
like my mom [ __ ] up like classic like
poor immigrant thing the second she got
some money she just got the cable
package with everything she just went
right my mom did weird flexes with her
money like she the second they start to
make money my mom got it cleaning lady
did it come three days a week who she
might be garbage because that's her
thing is like of all the ways you can
spend your money like you could like
develop like trusts you could find
differently my mom is like every single
day at least she spaced it out I like
the fact that she's space it out cuz it
would have been real tragedy if she had
them cuz you haven't come three days in
a row yeah and then [ __ ] Thursday to
Sunday you guys are [ __ ] struggling
alright perfect so there's a bit of a
new money aspect that yeah interesting
so was my dad do it was the same way
yeah my dad is like end of money so okay
dad's family had money back in like the
1800 or yeah like that money slowly back
like my dad's family business was called
auto typists and there were typewriters
mm-hmm like my grandfather like my
great-grandfather I think we're the
typewriter business so like basically
you're just seeing bit Jim right yeah
like falling apart but rich people don't
stop acting like they're rich yeah no
not at all not at all dude they got to
keep up appearances me especially man
hat or New York you got to keep up
[ __ ] appearances
I remember my girl telling me like her
grandparents like they were broke by the
time that they were like dead pretty
much but they made maybe like they had
like a hundred fifty thousand dollars
they like gave away a hundred thousand a
hundred fifty
thousand to charity because that's what
rich people did like so they had to show
yeah they've got a front like they had
money that have people so your dad's not
your dad's not like driving around the
city in his own limousine like driving
and then hopping but that legacy kind of
stopped through not with him like he is
zero egos or any of that kind of stuff
like he's one of six kids you know I
mean like he actually like enlisted
instead of like hey or something yeah so
it's like now he's a real one about it
but it just is interesting to see that
like kind of downward trend you know
okay yeah
balance your savings account every month
you know what I mean reconcile that [ __ ]
I think we need to donate this to Museum
yeah right we're getting a new whirlpool
what are you talking about I love it
alright so that's a pretty good dynamic
thank you that that's good info so that
kind of gives us that gives it's a lot
to work with here I want to start the
are you garbage questions in the house
with with your mom from Scotland
what uh what kind of soap would you guys
use in the shower did you have like a
bottle of like or bar soap or so like
Irish spring stuff like that like cheap
cheese yeah there isn't aren't they like
good cheapest like yeah like don't say
like my parent we moved into the dance
studio so we have 4,000 square foot loft
Jesus right that was it dancer and my
mom like trick the people in the
building use it was this is down in the
East Village where you had to be an
artist to buy it so my mom's I can teach
dance lessons then like oh they have
like one person in there if you want
swap
not [ __ ] like 80 people at a time
running up and down using the elevator
breaking [ __ ] leaving an air well you
know so everybody in the building
[ __ ] hated us the business did well
and then we moved in so we have this in
place but of course my mom is like Irish
Frank or padded shoulders I didn't have
anything in my refrigerator my entire
life we ate people meal was delivery my
mom does not know how to cook to save
her [ __ ] life really red sauce I'm
telling you you just you can't imagine
it's just like that's pretty trashy so
like no snacks in the house growing up
no nothing I mean maybe for roll-ups if
I really leaned in and picked up like we
had cereal boxes right but it was every
meal was ordered in Chile I would make
the chili in the canned chili if I was
hungry for a snack I remember going to
like people's houses and understand it I
was like they just feed you and they
give you drinks and snacks snacks oh
yeah dude Italian snacks and chewy bars
and all this other [ __ ] like just go in
there open it look through it and I just
closed it I gotta get the [ __ ] out of
here
dude I remember the first time I went to
my buddy's house same thing they were
Newmont like new money as that was a
construction worker there was really no
money there we found out at the at the
end of when that went I could when that
train crash but they opened up dude I
remember opening up his pantry door was
a walk in and he had fruit roll-ups
fruit by the foot and gushers I was like
dude this is like io9 at the [ __ ]
nest at Whole Foods
it was [ __ ] clean living
love a good pantry yeah that's that's a
he's fate in the picture man so with
that being said I want to work backwards
a little bit yeah right as far as they
are you garbage questions have you ever
taken a full-size pillow on an airplane
okay
that's [ __ ] yeah that's that's
bargain that's a bargain ticket right
there that's a middle seat if you're
walking on a [ __ ] plane with a
full-size pillow you're getting a middle
seat crazy okay while we're still out
like when you travel will you buy a meal
like in the terminal and then take it on
the plane and eat it yes you'll eat
anything like you get if you get like a
burger you'll take a burger on the plane
and eat it no because here's the reason
why I usually like I've been trying to
not eat like bread yeah find sugar
because it makes me kind of constipated
and also I'm vain and like I get to stay
in better shape without working out as
much sure well you can't do that on the
plane everything on the plane is a
version of nuts okay let me just get
some Asian [ __ ] in there okay speaking
of constipation will you [ __ ] on an
airplane I will [ __ ] in any location
really I can [ __ ] anywhere i prowl enjoy
it I look forward to it if I have to
take [ __ ] before we're about to take off
I hold it so I can yeah there's part of
you that's crazy you all you do have
this like you do have a [ __ ] wild
side to you I love some would say that's
garbage
I'm like that too I can [ __ ] anywhere I
don't even care about putting the paper
you put the toilet paper on the seat or
any of that [ __ ] I'm not gay oh I
wiped the ball so I can go cheap the
ball I'll do that I'll do that yeah well
for me unless untreatable I have to feel
my skin touching mm-hmm wool yeah I
spread my bunghole
yes pooping definitely that option
interest all right so you take your
shoes off on the plane depends depends
on what this is it so this could be a
good gauge it's also how tight the
sneaker is like my feet will swell up a
[ __ ] plan we're gonna type sneaker
yeah do it but if I'm wearing solution
rocket for a couple hours but you'll
keep them underneath the seat like a
gentleman you're not like flaunting your
feet around that being said actually no
no you know I sit on planes this is what
I do I put one foot in between the
armrests in front of me and then the
other foot in between that's [ __ ]
that is garbage that's garbage Schultz
I'm at the gyno baby I need my pap smear
you trashed you were behind Kevin he
would [ __ ] you got a bump my foot down
if I bang into your elbow it's staying
there until you do something oh my god I
can't look you the same anymore
okay I think you're we and also gender
it's not addition to me if you're a
woman and I bought the elbow and you
come back you have to nudge my foot off
of the armrest and then I'll let you
have it but I gotta see if you have this
guy is nuts
that's my [ __ ] seat I put the foot up
there before we take off so middle seat
knows what's going on
has anyone ever been like what the [ __ ]
are you doing all the time so I'm just
like it's so uncomfortable for me back
here like you should know that I'm sure
yeah terrible rationalization but I get
it I don't know for me it's like I'm
suffering and like actually resent when
I feel like shorter people take the
bigger leg room or like exit see like I
don't think that should be allowed in a
lot of ways I know you like
it's a meritocracy and everybody's
willing to pay more money they should be
able to access it I don't think it
should be allowed I don't think yeah I
don't know I like if you could pay if
you buy the seat you buy the seat that's
what I like
go look front you poor [ __ ] yeah that's
the problem that's that's that that's
poor person's first class right there to
me I would have spent the money to
[ __ ] if I could have got there yeah
folly has reserved his seat belt
extenders before he gets on the plane
yeah that happened once and I was bit so
embarrassing bro you gotta cut that [ __ ]
out
I'm working on it it was double
embarrassing because I was the I was in
the the place where you might have to do
something that something happens to open
the door
and for ya I was in the hero out and I
needed a seat extender and the guy came
up and he was like hey man listen if you
need a seat extender you can't be in the
hero aisle all right we don't want you
we're yeah we don't want you clocking up
the doorway fatty so not only did they
move they had the s2 in shape guys to be
in the hero seat and like some [ __ ]
Boy Scout in the back he's like I have
no problem doing it and then I had to
get up with my girlfriend go sit in his
seat and then the guy came back a couple
minutes later did holy [ __ ] now do you
think they were worried at all the first
thing that jumped out other world like
jump on top of you like the boat quick
get on his neck hanging on to me like
Leo and the Titanic
dude dude that's the most tragic have
cried if I saw that if I saw that in
real part real time that's garbage
this is all garbage I am the second that
they got that snack card out I was
[ __ ] double-fisting Cheetos - yeah
Christ let me ask you this what is the
most expensive pair of sweatpants that
you currently own
cuz that's class to me I
get my sweatpants when I go I'm Evan I
have an I'm a very sweaty pants it's
probably a pretty expensive what I maybe
I don't even know what the [ __ ] that is
holy [ __ ] that sounds like some [ __ ]
Illuminati [ __ ] I'm like let me look if
I don't know what it is folding
definitely doesn't know what it is let's
put it that way
I'm merely on door a it sounds fancy the
guys from [ __ ] Queens it's a killer
okay but it's like a fancy street where
Brent I'm gonna try and see how much
they can't be more than three hundo no
no okay okay
I'm probably a hundred and change maybe
that for a for a high-end I mean for a
high-end sweatpants that's what they're
going for Benson to make almost 200 well
you have to understand like I get most
of my sweatpants when I'm in Portland
and I go to the Nike employees yeah
everything in the store yeah so it's
like okay why the Nike tracksuits or
whatever getting an app off that's
hitting the outlets essentially shell
think about the Nike Lauri's it's all
the new [ __ ] don't you get that of an
inner can you just get in you got an air
he's got it in what are you talking
about he's wearing torn our first lap
dance which is my city
okay all right I got I got one this is
something me and Foley were talking
about the other day um if you had to go
to like an event you know you're going
to a First Holy Communion or something
along the lines and you had to wear a
basket you had to wear sports Jersey
okay
what is the classiest and least classy
sports Jersey I don't like a football
jersey a basketball jersey to not wear
to a sporting event you got to put it on
what's the trashiest one starting first
oh no what's the worst one to wear to a
yeah yes not as
Thanks Oh without a doubt
[ __ ] Knicks jersey like some basketball
jerseys the worst even a mess like you
could actually row
what are you gonna what else the Optus
where I'll wear a Sixers jersey to a
wedding
baseball jersey has buttons you could
argue that it's somewhat fancy I'll give
you that I'll give you that I'll give
you that I'll give you the buttons the
buttons if you got a button up right
there that's a buddy that's a button up
that's a fully functional button up
because it's like that's a sweater
they're called sweaters I think okay
easy what basketball jersey has got to
be the worst thing to wear anything I
don't know I feel like there's no point
in time you should ever wear be wearing
like a football jersey to anything
that's not a football game if I you ever
see some just a duty and dinner and a
football jersey that's not a nice
restaurant I guarantee you that like a
Rams Jersey that's [ __ ] guard yeah
especially if he's not in the city that
he's living in you know what I mean
ya know because they got the elastic on
the arms it looks like you got [ __ ]
shoulder pads on yeah dude you can only
wear football jersey football recently
yes yes that's that's my only point
yeah for sure
hmm all right grow it up did your family
ever have sherbert yeah problem that's
trashy you guys have beans does your
monitor make you beans for breakfast
that's a big Scottish thing
really dude that's bad if you're doing
if you're doing takeout breakfast that's
why she's gonna take out breakfast I
don't know about takeout but like my dad
would go out and he'd get like a pound
cake and some bagels or like we've had
cereal there that we could eat I'm
telling you there wasn't food in my
house growing up but not because my
parents didn't have money it was just
like they were busy to another [ __ ] like
yeah my mom my mom never learned the
rules to having money that's a
generational wealth thing where they are
aware and have nice folded cloths and
like all these little things that rich
people need to do with their money to
like prove that they're actually rich to
each other
my mom never learned that so she care
about [ __ ] value it like my mom didn't
care about having a nice car
she's like we'll just get the thing
where we could put enough stuff or we
can go to the beach she's like function
was like because she treated cars like
she was like I said cute she's they just
gave me a [ __ ] Toyota Sienna and then
we could go to the beach mm-hmm you know
like the Corolla did I I was either
I was given by my cousin my put my
cousin gave it's me white Toyota Corolla
oh that's a tough look on a car on my
car all this bad news that's pretty
trashy across America land at my school
I dropped my friends off that drove
across America with me as I'm exiting
their driveway slam into a boulder a
little bit Jesus Christ talk about a bad
[ __ ] luck yeah thank you
it's a good time all right so now now
obviously you're on spot are you live
with your girl or no live with your lady
do you guys do you
laundry in-house in the building or do
you do drop-off service you know pick up
sir you got one in the unit yeah that's
[ __ ] clean kids guys driven this
guy's a Kennedy holy [ __ ] I had that for
all right now what's the pin number I
need the last four digits of your social
security it does not have laundry in
unit Oh bad huh what laundry in the
building go downstairs that's a saving
grace a little bit not that many people
use it it's not like you're at like the
[ __ ] coin op place comp in laundry
and with a bunch of you know housewives
it's got a nice credit card thing yeah
clean puppy you're not pumping quarters
like a jerk-off I got a question for you
in your place now because I know is a
different situation growing up in your
place now is the big question on are you
garbage where do you keep your ketchup
and where do you keep your syrup just
rolling up the syrup was in the fridge
and might have been in the fridge too
all right that's what that's one out of
two it should be the open bottle of
ketchup in the refrigerator and an open
model of syrup is left in the cabinet I
agree right
leave the syrup out ketchup is a doozy
but all I try to leave almost all
condiments out maybe barbecue sauce I
keep in there
she's gotta keep it called barbecue
sauce you need a cold barbecue sauce if
you have butter in their house where do
you keep the butter you keep it in the
fridge you keep it out of the counter
now this this class the butters outside
the counter no garbage that's garbage
don't think about that Kevin garbage
garbage garbage garbage
now that's Oh does it that's it that's a
staple right now buddy tell you I'll
tell you garbage well garbage people
have a fear of things going bad
so they put everything in the fridge
when it doesn't have to be if they cover
the water with and they just leave it on
the counter because they want that
butter ready to be sliced and put on top
of a piece of bread at a moment's notice
not some frozen [ __ ] block that you
gotta like mash into the bagel and cut
through half the bagel to get it you
leave the butter out it's not even a
question so I'm gonna question no no
that's not a voltage it's different
deliveries but at night so this is my
thing you can keep it out you want to be
listen I grew up I grew up with the with
it with the glass thing with the top and
the butter and there I grew up with that
but the butter sleeps in the fridge it's
gotta sleep in the fridge you can't
leave the butter out overnight for five
for a week honestly I've never taken it
out I'm never putting it back in okay
not exactly sure I assume you leave it
out if it's pure class not that I do not
know actually can I tell you what I
think it is this is go ahead I think you
had one piece of in the outside thing
and then the rest of the butter stays in
the fridge sure yeah you better not have
us only put the piece that's in the out
something it could be half a stick I
think that's what it is okay
okay suspicion okay I'll give you that
I'll give you that
that's uh that's all I got for your show
it's Kippy you got any more questions I
think I got one or two more real quick
real quick here I'm still baffled by
that fetal not feed on the armrest on
the plane that's still [ __ ] baffles
my mind family vacation where would you
guys go on family vacations anywhere
that I would believe my family into
going to places with surfing because I
grew up a shoe usually revolves around
my hobbies like surfing or skateboarder
back oh yeah okay all right - my mother
hater
she's like Here I am yeah okay I gotta
say after the butter thing and just an
argument that you put forth through it
you're all class in my book and III do
have one more question I want to hit you
with and I know is gonna be yes - all
that's just gonna put it over the top
that schultzy is all class have you ever
dated any of the following you ready
okay a model yes an actor yes a
professional singer define professional
[Laughter]
Open Mic Center I'll give you something
like that okay
aspiring singer shorts okay okay
that's all class in my book hippie yeah
clean living I don't know he's got a
couple of blemishes in the file but
overall we think you're all class
Schulte thank you so much for sitting in
with this is there anything you want the
folks out there to know that they that
they might not know which I doubt it but
anything you want to let them know
anyway I'm uncomfortable it's trash if
its class either way I'm honored to be
judged by you guys
I wish you the best of luck with this
man and I can't wait to get back into
the clubs and do some shows to that
sentence thanks again guys everybody
makes you check out Andrew Shope she's
all over just about everywhere you could
possibly think of this guy is there if
you don't already know which I'm sure
you do that's why you listen to this
check him out the King Andrew Schultz
thank you buddy
hey guys that's a lot with this